[music playing]
Up there is pure energy
in its rawest form.
It's exactly what I need.
[sighing]
[grunting]
Wild honey-- a nutritious
calorie-packed hit of energy.
It's pretty special stuff.
But getting it is never easy.
[screaming]
I'm getting stung all over.
I just keep getting
nailed by bees.
My plan is simple.
I'm using this rope ladder I've
made so I can position myself
right next to the entrance.
I can hear them buzzing.
That is the landing
pad for the thousands
of bees that live inside
this tree where the honey is.
Cutting into here means I
won't damage the hive above.
Oh, yeah.
They're coming.
You see them?
They know I'm here.
Oh, yeah they're coming out now.
But this wood is like concrete.
I'm just aggravating the bees.
I have to try
something different.
[grunting]
[screaming]
[spitting]
They're coming out in force.
I just have to reach inside.
Ugh.
My eyelids.
Just a few sticky
handfuls are enough.
[grunting]
Yeah.
[sputtering]
Time to get out of here.
[screams]
[grunting]
Another day in the jungle.
Yeah.
They're still
everywhere my hair.
Pain is a price worth paying.
This could be my
only food for days.
So good.
Mm.
Pure honey-- straight
from the hive.
This is amazing.
[music playing]